there there's a teacher who's of course
of course taken to tick-tock
thank goodness for tick-tock tick-tock
is the greatest honey pot that
conservatives ever invented i'm starting
to think xi jinping is on our side
because tick-tock just attracts these
lunatics and predators to go on the
platform and confess they're extremely
creepy and in some cases criminal
behavior
and then then there's a great twitter
account called libs of tick tock that
takes that from tick tock where
adult conservatives generally are not to
twitter where we are and posts it for us
so libs of tick tock just found this
lady she's complaining
that her second grade students
did not understand the phrase non-binary
gender
so today in queer teacher things um one
of my students asked about my roommate
um because i know i have a roommate and
i told them their name and they asked my
roommate was a boy or girl and i said
neither and they were like no miss brown
are they a boy or a girl
i was like my friend they're neither
they were like well do they have a boy
name or a girl name and i said neither
and they said well do they wear boy
clothes or girl clothes and i said well
what are boy clothes and girl clothes
and they go you know
and i said no my friend i don't know
what our boy closing girl clothes and
they said well what kind of clothes do
they wear and i said
well they normally wear jeans and a
t-shirt and they said well what color is
the t-shirt and i said
all colors and they said well that
doesn't make any sense and i said it
doesn't have to make sense and then they
walked away because they got mad at me
out of the mouth of babes such wisdom
out of the mouth of babes
and credit to this teacher at lee well
i don't want to give the devil as due
here but i will give the devil her due
in that at the end she acknowledges that
it doesn't make sense
the kids say this doesn't make sense and
she says yeah
it doesn't have to make sense
she's she's
calling her second grade students my
friend my friend like she's a
middle easterner at a bazaar trying to
sell you cheap goods my friend my friend
i am selling you non-binary my friend my
friend for you good good price best
price for you my friend on transgender
pangender non-binary my friend
then the students say well hold on
your roommate their
gender it their t-shirt their color it
doesn't it doesn't have to make sense
and she's right she's right
society doesn't have to make sense
we can live in a
chaotic
anarchistic
cacophonous
mayhem of a society we can and
increasingly that is what we are doing
but if you want education to be
education if you want to make sense of
your freedom if you want to cultivate
your rational will if you want to get
along and flourish
that does have to make sense we do need
sense we do need logic and reason when
the libs have to choose between
educating the children that they seem to
care so much about
educating them giving them a good
education teaching them to make sense of
their freedom and advancing their insane
political sexual cultural ideology which
are they going to pick 100 times out of
100 it is going to be the latter
the sexual indoctrination of children
starts at a very young age
and this is true by the way
in all cultures and in all societies
this is the one point that the libs get
right actually when the libs say that we
need to teach
sex to kindergarteners
they're they're right in the sense that
when you read a story book when a normal
kindergarten teacher in a normal
kindergarten class in a normal society
something we haven't had in a long time
when that teacher reads a book a board
book about mama bear and papa bear and
baby bear to the class that is a kind of
sexual instruction because what it's
saying is
that family looks a certain way and that
marriage looks a certain way and that
men and women relate to one another in a
certain way
and when men and women come together in
this thing called marriage through some
kind of process you get little baby bear
and and so that is a kind of sexual
teaching
what the libs want is extremely creepy
perverse pornographic disordered sexual
teaching so obviously that's very bad
but but there's always
they are right that there is always a
kind of sexual instruction going on
because men and women are different
we're exposed to them from the very
beginning and
we ask um mommy what what why are you
and daddy married well when a man and a
woman love each other very much they
come together and they get married and
they start a family oh okay mommy all
right and then when the little kid's
really little is mommy where do babies
come from well you came from mommy's
belly then the kid gets older and they
get a little bit more into detail but
that that does start
from an early age and so i have
i have a great deal of sympathy
for parents who are who are falling prey
to the left's
perversions here there's a couple that
uh just again took to tick tock
took to took to the honey pot
to explain
how their daughter
knew that she was a boy
starting around age two
you ready
on the 6th of march we welcomed our
beautiful twins into the world a boy
called arlo and a girl called emerald
the first one they said was this is a
girl i genuinely remember your face just
like lighting up like this is amazing
and then the next one is on this is a
boy
jackpot you know one of each this is the
perfect combination here
look at that
so now they're four years old and
they identify as two boys
the first time that i realized stormy
wanted to identify as male was about
roughly two and a half
but
it's not really he said i want to be a
boy he said i am a boy
and that is the difference
my name is stormy and i'm four years old
i feel like a boy and i want to be a boy
sometimes people call me girl
do they how does that make you feel sad
when you watch this
you get very angry if you're a normal
person you can't help but get angry you
say this poor kid the kid can barely
speak he's a four-year-old he says
i'm a boy now or i said he because it's
so confusing that does she she says
i'm a boy and i know and so you're
telling me at two and a half
the baby knew that she was a boy no this
owes to the
confusion of the parents and the
confusion of this culture
when i was a four-year-old i said i was
batman i really did i went for like two
weeks i put on a cape and i demanded
that everyone call me batman i know that
conservatives use this as a kind of
flippant example that i actually did
that when i was four when i was the age
that that little girl is now
and
my mother tolerated my wearing the cape
a little bit but she never she never uh
embraced my identity entirely as a
billionaire who fights crime if only she
had i would have loved to be treated
like a billionaire as a little kid but
it would not have been good for my
flourishing because it wasn't true
wasn't
it wasn't in accord with reality even
still as angry as one gets at these
parents
i have a great deal of sympathy because
these parents in particular
admitted they said man this seems
so crazy it seems so so crazy but i just
i just want to do what's best for my kid
i can't remember the exact moment it
switched over but there was that point
where i thought you know what this isn't
just this isn't just a phase this is not
a little girl we're looking at it's a
little boy
he started being unhappy with being
dressed as the girls who started being
happy wearing dresses hair clips were a
big no-no didn't like hair clips didn't
like the pigtails he was genuinely
upset at being dressed as a girl before
i had children and certainly before the
last couple of years this whole thing
that i'm saying i i would have thought
it was ridiculous honestly i would i
would have i would have watched me
and said no you you're crazy you're
making it up you're abusing a child
we constantly say are you a boy today or
do you feel like you might because i
don't want you to feel like you took
himself down a route that he can't turn
back
i'm really glad that this couple
included this explanation it
in a way it redeems them and the abuse
that they are carrying on against their
daughter
because i bet there are a lot of parents
who feel this way
who say
well you know my my child is has a
little bit of a fantasy but but the
culture tells me that if i don't affirm
the fantasy then i'm going to make my
kid commit suicide that's what they tell
you
they say if you do not affirm this
child's fantasy
the kid's going to kill him or herself
and it's going to be your fault
and
any parent will do anything to protect
their kid but the the parents obviously
have some trepidation here and they say
but i don't want put the power my
daughter down a path you know feel like
she's gone down a path where she can't
get back but necessarily she will be
especially when kids are really really
little their brains are like sponges
they're so malleable
the more they behave in a certain way
the more they are going to behave in a
certain way that's true of all of us
that's just what habit is but especially
when you're a kid you form habits much
more easily and they can stick a lot
longer that's why it's so much easier to
learn a foreign language when you're a
little kid than when you're older and
and so the longer that they do this and
then obviously if they end up using
puberty blockers or cross-sex hormones
or any of the poison that the psychos in
big pharma and in our the cultural left
are forcing on little kids then they
then they're on a path where it's
virtually impossible to get back
i just would encourage parents who are
in this position
do not allow yourself to fall prey to
the insane psychotic false emotional
blackmail do not allow yourself to to
distrust your gut instinct your gut
instinct is right our
even our medical establishment certainly
the cultural establishment but even our
medical establishment is completely
without credibility they they are the
emperor without clothes they've proven
that i think definitively over the last
two years and and now it's no longer
about making you wear some stupid cloth
mask now it's about permanently
destroying your little child's body do
not believe them trust your gut
i'm glad you like that clip now you know
what you have to do you gotta ring smash
click
like tap
dab twerk i don't know you gotta
subscribe to the michael knowles show
right here on youtube and also on apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
make sure to do that right this very
second we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]